a little sad news obviously I can't
imagine what you're going through in the
public eye especially promoting in
record when you have to do all this
press so you want to tell you that I am
sorry you guys are both creepy I know
but I work you know what though works
great friends Josh and I but there's so
much love that we have for each other
yeah we really like each other we have
fun with each other but we are still
Axl's parents through and through and
our families each other's family the
cousin my nieces and nephews it's all
the same you're in so that's that's the
only thing that's changed and so you
know is that the most important thing in
this situation though just making sure
Axl's happy does he understand
absolutely
oh good there's no even for any of that
right now but there's just a yeah
there's really been it's just been all
love in our family our families our
families together and that cannot change
that is Axl's family the cousins I need
all of my of the demons and the
categories and everybody that I fall in
love with their family there's been so
many changes in your life in this year
you tell me what is the next five years
of you being a musician and an
entrepreneur an artist look like in your
head bringing the family
Axel's every year making sure that life
is balanced and yeah they're just an
open vessel everything has to be done
with love
[Music]
you